[Music]
is the end goal here that abortion be
illegal and it be criminalized and
removed as a resource forever from this
country is that the illegal and
unthinkable illegal and unthinkable so
it is criminalized and stigmatized
[Applause]
[Music]
if you agree step forward if you
disagree stay put
nobody likes abortions
i don't think anyone likes it i think
they use it and they might use it
incorrectly from my perspective but i
don't think anyone likes
an abortion like they're not like
jumping for joy for it i think it is a
very physically taxing
process to go through and i don't think
anyone
would want to intentionally have an
abortion i think those who get an
abortion most of the time it's because
they need to it's a harmful narrative on
both sides of the conversation to say
that you know women celebrate abortion i
think it creates a prejudice around
women who do get abortions
and i i don't think that it's good to
kind of minimize the decision of
abortion from either side from the
perspective so can the disagree or step
forward
i think if you asked me this question
maybe several years ago i would have
said nobody likes abortion but i think
in today's climate it is much more
celebrated as a pro-life person i've had
people tell me that they will dedicate
their next abortion to me
um instead of helping women they will
have an abortion i've had i've heard
very similar responses to you things
like i'll donate to planned parenthood
in your name and there's other pages
like shout your abortion that
openly celebrates
abortion rights yeah i celebrate
abortion and i think that campaigns like
shout your abortion aren't about like
getting in your face
but women who choose to have abortions
uh suffer a lot of stigma and trauma
from people who stand outside clinics
and have grotesque images and
literally you know damning
your soul
abortion as a medical procedure and
resource is something that i do
celebrate it's a human right
and i love abortion
my name is rocky i use she her pronouns
i'm from austin texas and i am very
pro-abortion i think that legislation
like sb8 opens the door and the path
towards
handing over our bodily autonomy to the
state i don't understand how
anyone can justify using their personal
beliefs to take away the rights of
others
my name is abby i'm from orlando florida
and i'm an abolitionist of human
abortion we have to ask the question of
what makes humans valuable so because my
worldview as a christian
gives me a foundation for human worth
and because i believe scientifically
fetuses are human beings from the moment
of conception i am against abortion
biological fathers should have an equal
say in abortions
[Music]
well i think so i mean it's consistency
like if we're defining that as a life if
it is life to put a kid up for adoption
both parents have to agree i agree i
have talked to
lots of women who've had abortions and
i've talked to lots of men who are
hurting they're they're completely
heartbroken they would have raised the
baby they wanted to raise the baby they
begged for the life of the baby and they
obviously created the baby together but
only one of them gets to decide if their
child gets to live or die i would like
to say from more of a honestly feminist
perspective
men have responsibility as the other
parent of that child ironically enough a
lot of the times when pro-choice people
put the focus completely on the woman
they strict the man of all his parental
rights and responsibilities and i think
that's why actually a lot of men who are
pro-choice are pro-choice because they
don't want to have those fatherly
responsibilities that they will have
once the child is born
you left us man i want to know why
i'm mad conflicted about this because i
strongly feel like a man
should not
have control over what a woman does with
her body
i more so have an issue with
when a man doesn't actually want that
baby she wants it
and then expects
this man to like be the ultimate
provider and child
care and all this extra stuff right but
in the case of if the man wanted it the
baby and the woman didn't want it he has
no say-so i think that's a dynamic
so that's why i was going back and forth
well you should have stayed then it
sounds like you it sounds like you're
four men having more rights i just i
just can't force a woman to be like no
you have to do this because i think it's
[ __ ] up it's her body but it's also a
child's life in there it's not just her
body's a child's life also your son or
daughter i think truly in my eyes it's
like it's my body i get to do what i
want with it and i don't think anyone
including the person the other person
who's involved should have a say whether
i want to keep it or whether i want to
get an abortion
my name is asher i currently reside in
las vegas and i'm for pro-abortion i
used to be against
abortion until an unwanted pregnancy
happened to me
if you know for a fact that you're not
even going to be the best parent for
that child or you can't provide for that
child or maybe you're just fearful and
don't want to pop a child out of you or
just whatever reason that you have i
feel like you shouldn't have to go
through that you still have that choice
over your life your body
i have had an abortion
a few months ago
i
found out that i was pregnant when i
imagined myself
finding out i was pregnant for the first
time
i wanted it to be celebrated
and in that moment i felt such severe
anxiety
and i felt and
having that i felt i like the entire
time i was just in a lot of emotional
pain grieving i was debating
about myself about what how i would be
looked at or how i would view myself
after getting the procedure done
uh i ain't gonna lie i'm nervous so i'll
be real careful with my words clearly as
a man i can't have an abortion but
uh my girlfriend
um we've had two abortions she didn't
really want to have a baby i didn't
really want to have a baby and i know
for me i don't want to be that seen as
that deadbeat
father person but i knew i wasn't
really trying to sacrifice my own dreams
or what i was trying to accomplish to be
a dad at that point i think that's
definitely like one of the biggest
things to consider because i wasn't in
any kind of position to be a mother you
know so it's like i want to get my [ __ ]
together before i can have a baby and
give it a life that it deserves
when i found out i was pregnant the
person that i was with at the time they
were like i will support you in every
way but i will not be able to be there
for you
if you decide to keep it and that
definitely influenced my choice it was
one of the hardest decisions i've ever
had to make i like to think i'm a pretty
generous like loving person and the
names that i've been called for even
getting one i've gotten evil psychotic
demented
my name is christine i'm from denver and
i am
on the anti-abortion side so when i was
20 years old i was a college student and
i found myself in an unplanned pregnancy
and i was pressured to abort very
heavily not only by my child's father
but
by those around me and
i heard my son's heartbeat and it there
was no debate it was a life his life was
not mine to take this is part of why i
am very pro-life because i know many
women are pressured to abort when they
don't want to
can they disagree a step forward
your story is absolutely
powerful and your story as well i think
something we probably all can agree on
is abortion usually is a symptom of a
bigger problem whether it's finances
whether it's
stability of housing whether it's
relationship issues my perspective is
that we address those issues
instead of ending the life of a child i
disagree
i don't think that abortion is a symptom
people should be able to access abortion
when hair how wherever
they want or need i don't think that
it's a problem to be fixed i think that
is still stigmatizing but i think the
biggest thing is
there are birth control methods out
there and abortion should not be a birth
control method i think that that's very
critical and and to hear that you know
you weren't celebrated i think life
should be celebrated with everybody i'd
like to call attention to that point too
just the effect of using abortion as
birth control i thank you for everyone
sharing their stories so far i didn't
step forward i haven't had an abortion
myself but i am a survivor of rape i was
on birth control at the time and i still
made the decision with my medical team
that birth control is not 100 effective
and i wanted access to emergency
contraceptive to take on top of that and
had that pregnancy or any of those
methods failed
i would have chosen to have an abortion
and i'm very grateful that i had access
to those resources and i'm so mindful
that there's so many women who don't
well i think it gets down to the heart
of the issue here you know what is the
unborn which scientifically the embryo
is from conception a living whole
organism with distinct dna as a
christian i come from a worldview that
says that every human being is has
dignity and worth not to disrespect any
any religion in general but in my eyes
that's just pushing a belief onto
someone rather than actually stating a
real real concrete fact so um
scientifically i'm pro-life because of
science not because of religion but
scientifically i believe that life does
start at conception i don't think it
makes sense to put life beginning at any
other place during pregnancy um doing so
usually ends up saying that a already
born person isn't alive
such as consciousness heartbeat etc
there are many pro-life people here here
from the science perspective
who are not led by religious motives at
all or partially
i am ayala i am 18 years old i am from
charlotte north carolina and i am
anti-abortion one misconception that i
deal with pretty frequently is that
we're all
christian white old men and as a you
know jewish woman
younger i really want more voices like
mine to be seen in the anti-abortion
movement because i think we have new
perspectives that would help kind of
bridge the gap and have us find a little
bit of middle ground between our two
opposing sides
abortion is murder
i think it is murder i think
for the abortionist more so than the
woman i think a lot of women don't
necessarily know
exactly how an abortion procedure is
formed i've had a girl even tell me that
at 20 weeks a baby is just a clump of
cells and that's just not true i i do
believe now there might be cases where
some women might be unaware of of what
what's going on in an abortion but by
and large i think especially with the
advent of the internet and so much
education out there many of them do know
that the life that there's a life inside
of them and they want to to end that
life whether they call it murder or not
hard disagree absolutely disagree okay
um i've definitely met a lot of teenage
girls who grew up in our generation who
believe that abortion is normal a fetus
is a clump of cells and there is no
human life in the womb they don't tell
you when you go into an abortion
consultation this is a child and this is
a human life and that's what's going to
be happening i have a hard time
believing that if most women knew they
were killing a child they would do that
i don't think women in america are that
malevolent i think it's very
irresponsible and very hurtful to say oh
this woman's a murderer because she had
an abortion
at least my personal experience the
people who worked there were very
understanding they let me know there is
a child that will that could come out of
you in nine months are you sure you want
to do this i knew there was a child in
my body i knew i could have a child in
nine months and i knew that that child
can grow old and be their own person but
i made that choice because i'm allowed
to have that choice and especially you
you are a white man you and you are not
allowed to say what i can do with my
body nor any of these other women who
are able to carry a child i think that's
so dangerous i think that's so dangerous
to say that you can't say because of
your sexuality who you are as a male or
female or how you believe as a religion
you can't define what's right and wrong
i think that's misguided and we should
take that into policy i think what
you're saying is that whatever your your
morality is i think that you know folks
are entitled that we have freedom of
religion we have freedom from religion
whatever your moral value is the issue
is trying to turn that into legislation
and putting legislatively we legislate
what's right and wrong all the time
thinking even medically you know like
for indigenous women they're two times
as likely to die from pregnancy-related
complications who's responsible for that
murder if she's forced to carry that
baby well i would be i would be off
working on legislation altogether where
you know if the woman's been taken
advantage of or if they've uh in such
situations or if her life's at risk
we can keep those options on the table
so all of a sudden because she could
potentially die will make legislation
where she can't abort that baby and all
of a sudden you're pro-abortion no i'm
not pro-abortion i personally would not
like her to choose that option i think
science is kind of frightening no no no
no no no no i think science has come a
long way where that that's vastly not
the case anymore within our medical
community and we need to continue to
increase funding for those mechanisms to
provide more research on how to keep the
woman alive
what is the is the end goal here that
abortion be illegal and it be
criminalized and removed as a resource
forever from this country is that the
illegal and unthinkable illegal and
unthinkable so it is culturally for
women we want women to have resources
first of all to where they don't need an
abortion and then abortion for the
abortionist is criminalized so an
abortionist could go to jail for
performing it women should not be
criminalized because at the end of the
day women are victims of abortion as
well
my name is sebastian king and i am
anti-abortion side my mom had an
unplanned pregnancy because she was
taken advantage of from the time she was
to 15 and she was in and out of state
custody and the judge even encouraged
her to have an abortion and told my mom
that she won't amount to anything in
life if she goes through with this
pregnancy because she chose life i'm
that's the only reason i'm here today
and that's my mission is to ensure that
all life is protected
abortion should be accessible to rape
and incest survivors
if you're pregnant from your brother or
your cousin or your father especially if
it wasn't consensual or even if it was
you should still have that option to
abort the baby and especially if you've
been raped there are some people who
have that thought like oh my god like
what if i when i look at my child i
relive that trauma
and not saying that's how all
rape victims view it but it's just like
some women have that fear
okay
so
i was raped for four years of my life
violently
more times than i can count
and i did get pregnant when i was 15. my
rapists threatened me with abortion
multiple times
used that as a tool to keep me in his
power if he had the power to terminate
evidence he had power against me
um i did end up losing her but i wanted
her very badly i named her heil which is
rachel in english
and i think it's very important to
humanize people who are conceived in
rape because they're walking around
right now there's a lot of them there's
a lot of them and i think it is it's
very insulting to place that on a human
being i think that humans no matter how
they are conceived are human beings and
they deserve to be respected and their
lives deserve to be respected and i
agree because that's me
and my mom has always told me
she doesn't view me as his even on my
birth certificate he's not my father so
also i want to tap on what you said
though cause you said you really wanted
to keep your daughter and although you
don't you know see it as the rape baby
and stuff other people who also go
through that traumatic experience may
actually see it like that right
you wanted that but there's other people
that had their a choice taken away from
them they shouldn't be shamed they're
going through this even having to live
through that experience of the rape baby
here's the thing
when you get an abortion as a reaction
to rape you're continuing continuing the
cycle of violence so you were raped that
was a violent experience that happened
to you that wasn't your fault you're
hurt you've been victimized um why is it
fair to further victimize someone else
because you are hurt
but you're seeing it as a someone know
man i'm putting myself in a woman's
shoes or a human being's shoes right you
take my choice away you write me and who
for all you know i might be a struggling
struggling human being right making
eight dollars an hour something like
that crazy bills i might be living in my
car i might be sleeping in the dumpster
behind mcdonald's but now because of
your opinion right and my traumatic
experience i get shamed because i don't
want to bring this life into the world
bro oh but you should give birth and
then put in foster care if you don't
want it but i want to touch on that too
just for a second like for trauma i
think
absolutely what i am passionate about is
giving people the choice and for you you
thought a lot about your choice and you
wanted that pregnancy and i'm really
sorry that you lost that child and i
also thought a lot about for myself when
i went through that experience what
choice would be best for me and for me
that was not caring the child and i
think trauma is such an interesting
thing for me not having control over a
child growing inside of me and changing
my fate of my life you know that would
be more traumatic than the initial
experience we don't know how people are
going to react but i do fight and would
want them to have the choice to do
what's best for them
i think a strange misconception that
people have about people who are
pro-abortion is that we don't have
respect for life or we don't care about
children that's absolutely not true i
respect life very much unfortunately
i've also seen a lot of
negative aspects of our systems in the
us like the foster care system it's out
of that respect that i believe people
should have the right to choose an
abortion
america offers resources
to help you raise a
child there's tax benefits to having
children
i think there was also uh you know in
the latest round of covered money there
was funding for women who've had
children yeah and there are so many um
christian charities and so many
different organizations that
that want to help women you know and and
the resources are there also government
resources there are government resources
that help you take care of children um
are there enough that is a different
question i was basically just agreeing
with what you said because section 8
food stamps free health care school
programs and whatnot like there are
resources are there enough that's that's
how my mom survived when she had me
because of government assistance so
that's the only way she that's the only
way she made it because of that
i have been
a pregnant
teenager
and i've also been a teenage mother
on welfare and
unemployed the number of resources that
are available state to state is
something that is atrocious but what it
comes down to is a lot of time and
energy
the choice between do i go to work and
get the money to pay rent or do i go and
i sit in the office or do i go to this
non-profit who's requiring me to fill
out this application and come to a
meeting in the day time when i'm
supposed to be working so you see it
kind of like a job like you're clocking
in to fill in paperwork
resources and creating these sort of
impossible hurdles and more barriers for
people who are already experienced them
to overcome to get the help is not a
help at all and i feel like a completely
like separate conversation is it is
extremely hard to be
a single
mother who is also a woman
or person of color and to get resources
especially black women they are
notoriously even in that room where
they're giving birth they
they aren't taken seriously well i just
want to say one thing because i think
it's important so i might not look it
but i'm native american have my cherokee
card and everything we have universal
health care in the indian community and
um when she went to have me as a child
they told her in that universal health
care system that she's not she doesn't
she's not allowed to have pain medicine
because that's a luxury so she got it
through government assistance so that
that's a big deal that the united states
is
for than the native american community
i'm glad we're just alone
no no i'm not saying that's acceptable
i'm not saying that's acceptable but i'm
saying like it exists it exists that
that story exists but there are literal
reservations out there that do not have
water do not have electricity do not
have internet that is in 2021 are those
not resources to raise a child so let's
find the government of killing that they
say that the government the question
does the government provide resources no
does america provide resources no that's
unacceptable
abortions will continue to happen
regardless of the law
of course
all right well that ain't never gonna
change i think of course they'll
continue to happen a law doesn't mean
that something is not gonna happen at
all anymore just like rape just like
murder just like anything else we've
outlawed just because they're still
going to happen
doesn't make it right but if you
criminalize
doctors and abortion providers right
that means we no longer have providers
that means abortion is no longer an
option and that by default the way that
this country and especially my state
legislates will mean and it has happened
we have precedent
a woman who tries to self-induce or who
tries other non-medical methods to have
an abortion can and has been
criminalized what is the
policy that doesn't just absolutely take
away
the
right that people have to access an
abortion regardless of what their
own beliefs are if if that child is a
human being deserving of the right to
life then yes it should be criminalized
just like murder of two-year-olds and
five-year-olds and adults is
criminalized right but that's that's
that's so different though he's got
people that's you have people that's two
years old already out the womb they've
been here for years right and then you
got these sales can i ask you something
when does it stop being a clump of cells
personally i'm not worried about the
clump of cells decades of medical
research has not been able to land on
that answer i'm trying to answer your
question as far as do you believe that
abortion should be allowed all nine
months of pregnancy i do feel
that's a bit more extreme so
i will agree on that but why is it more
expensive wait but let's not act like
women are just deciding to get abortions
at like during their second or third
trimester and the women who are doing it
it's either that they're going to die
giving birth or it's under some medical
circumstances because no i doubt even
myself i'd doubt that i would get to a
six month seven month mark and then
decide oh actually i don't want to make
this commitment i feel like there's a
lot of this conversation like when does
it become wrong
as if we're actually going to get an
abortion at that time
[Music]
a lot of the um what pro-life people
would consider
hostile uh pro-choice um comments and
things like that are a response to
hostile pro-life people um and i think
that doesn't get talked about on our
side because we don't like to fight each
other um but i think it's an important
point because i've seen absolutely
disgraceful comments made towards women
who are going into clinics you know who
are obviously in a very traumatizing
situation um and you know what that
woman is going through and they're
shining obscenities at her and i that
that's appalling and i think that we
need to take responsibility as pro-life
people to understand they've experienced
so much hurt from our side of the
community and i agree with that i think
but from our side of the aisle folks are
very passionate because they believe
that's a life they believe that's a baby
and they want to do everything they can
to save that child but i agree that our
rhetoric needs to be there as a resource
and another option and we can do that
peacefully and respectfully as well i
think on any side of any controversial
issue you're always going to have those
extremists same thing on the
pro-abortion side people are always
going to have feelings and people are
always going to fight on that level
right but i think it's about coming up
here and saying like what actually makes
common sense and how do we come up with
policy that doesn't force
folks to live by
other people's values
[Music]
you